four live local now tomorrow marks one
week since a beam collapsed on the u.s
95 killing a metro detective our eight
news now i-team is working to find out
more about how this happened thanks for
joining us here at four i'm kirsten
joyce and i'm christian casadas the
i-team's vanessa murphy is here with
more on new details she just tracked
down vanessa
yeah we've just learned what that beam
is built to withstand according to the
nevada department of transportation it
should be able to take a hit from a 10
ton vehicle going up to 65 miles per
hour the clearance is 15 feet high now
still the two main questions here was
that early warning being properly
secured and did the truck which collided
with it have the proper permit from ndot
a spokesman says ndot can't provide more
info until state police do because state
police are heading this investigation
state police still aren't providing
additional details though tomorrow again
marks one week and those questions
remain as we reported an oversized
tractor trailer collided with the early
warning beam on u.s 95 at the centennial
bowl project we don't know if that truck
weighed more than 10 tons or if it was
going faster than 65 miles per hour but
the beam collapsed and landed on a car
metro detective justin terry was driving
terry a husband and father of two died
at that scene an ndot spokesman says for
their investigation state police took
the beam and the pieces used to secure
it but one just like it is back up las
vegas paving is doing that construction
western states contracting owns that
truck six days later both companies are
saying no comment now we've heard from
many viewers about this tragedy because
some of you recall driving under that
beam before this happened again at this
point we're still waiting on the state
police here back to you
vanessa thank you for that well we have
details for the funeral service and
procession honoring fallen detective
justin terry the public will be able to
pay their respects to the 45 year old
husband and father during two
visitations tomorrow and saturday
evening at palm cheyenne mortuary monday
morning the detective will be escorted
in a police procession to henderson's
central christian church for a 10 a.m
service now more details are posted on
our website 8newsnow.com